so Ryan set people's understanding of
timeline in mind I mean you started
episode eight while episode 7 was very
much still in production I did yeah yeah
they were still shooting actually here
in London they were still shooting
episode 7 and so yeah I was thinking
about that today because obviously a
colin is doing the same thing while
we're what we were in production with
episode 8 he was starting to think about
nine and I know it was kind of strange
like because we one of the first things
I did was went up to San Francisco and
spent about six weeks kind of figuring
out the story and I would go in a few
times a week and sit down with these
guys and with the story group and just
hash it through and we would watch
dailies that were coming in from 7:00
and at that point it was just a script
and kind of the dailies that we were
seeing and I was thinking about that I
think I was probably really healthy that
in thinking about where the story goes
next it was entirely just based on our
reactions to it as opposed to based on
the phenomenon that it would become her
the cultural reaction to it it was just
a very personal what do we connect with
about with these characters and and
where did they go next I think was a
good thing yeah you were coming to
understand who our new leads our new
heroes and villains where you were
coming to understand hooray fen Po and
kylo were just as they were actually
still coming together yeah yeah it
really was a yeah it was a unique
experience so when it came to you you
came aboard and this is just a tip for
any future filmmakers a real smart way
to get your foot in the door at
Lucasfilm if you ever have a meeting
with us is to bring homemade ice cream
our very first story meeting with Ryan
he's like he surprises us all by
bringing us ice cream which is like it
was we're gonna expect this man yeah we
can expect this for that woman no but
what you did which I thought was really
great is we began sort of a film camp so
to speak
Ryan assembled movies that he thought it
was important for us to watch and
understand his point of view about them
so
we'd had this common language and I
would love for you to share some of the
titles that we watched well it was I
mean there was also stuff that I really
wanted to because we were in the middle
of you know it's a middle coming up with
what the stuff is going to be and there
was also stuff where I thought it would
be really good to rewatch this and it's
funny like at the time so we were it was
12 o'clock high it was a letter never
sent it was what else did we watch watch
Bridge on the River Kwai that's right
bridge on the river kwai dam Busters
which won three outlaw Samurai oh that's
right three outlaws Samurai that's
really watched Rupert no wait no we
didn't watch Hooper yeah we you and I
watch Cooper Shepherd that was a pretty
intense right yeah uh so let's hear that
story we'll get to that we'll get to
that I so know it but it's funny
actually watching now being we were just
at the end of production right now and
going through and looking at the film
that we put together and looking back at
the movie like particularly 12 o'clock
high
there was a seeing oh my god a lot of
that made it made it in there like at
the time it was just like oh this will
be kind of a fun bonding thing and maybe
there will be things here there but that
you then end up actually being a really
really crucial part of it watched Gunga
Din remember that Gunga Din that's right
that and we watched Sahara not the
Matthew McConaughey's Sahara that the
Humphrey Bogart Sahara where he's a tank
commander and my favorite part is like
we're at Skywalker Ranch we're sitting
there watching this and Ben Burtt sticks
his head in and his first question is
who's watching Sahara and it made him
love us yeah totally anyone who'll dig
up Sahara and watch it in the theaters
it's gotta be good people so when we
announced that Episode eight was in
production we had a little video that we
showed a view basically recreating the
scene between Mark and Daisy at scale
like so could you talk about that yeah
that was a really surreal way to start
the whole thing out so we that it was
when we started coming up with you know
I started coming with the story I
realized that I wanted to I immediately
kind of even really think about it the
notion that we were going to end up
breaking kind of a long-standing Star
Wars tradition and for the first time
this movie is going to start right where
the last one left off because it was
like I don't want to skip ahead
at last moment it was seven I want to
see what happens next and so just
because of the demands of the story
that's what it ended up being which
meant we went back to two Skellig and we
were only able to get a couple days of
shooting there and it was months before
we started principal photography so it
was really the first first thing that we
did and it was a very surreal I mean the
island itself is this amazing it feels
like you're stepping into a history it
feels I guess there is something very
mystical and magical about the island
Rick Carter had described it to me
before I went there in his very Rick
Carter way and it's a very Rick Carter
plate it's like an incredibly mystical
place so to be there and be the first
thing that we're shooting is you know
Mark and Daisy standing up on on
Christ's saddle and done skellig michael
and it was just so I know it was an
appropriately surreal beginning to the
whole experience and this was before
anyone really knew like that that moment
would become so iconic to the world so
so wow that's good I didn't need that
extra press not so paralyzed by fear
yeah let's talk about working with some
of the classic cast you know before we
go into that I just want to understand
like what your level of of Star Wars
appreciation was going into all this and
then what it meant to have Mark Hamill
and Carrie Fisher and people like
Anthony Daniels in front of you and and
they're yours to direct now yeah I mean
I feel like it in a lot of conversations
I've had just over the past few years I
feel like it almost you almost want to
lead with an apology like I know
everyone has a this is what Star Wars
means to me story this year sounds
almost g0p debate is something that's so
integral Star Wars was that I mean it
was the it was the first I have this
memory of my dad putting me in the car
to take me to see Star Wars and I asked
him where are we going he said we're
going to see the most amazing thing
you've ever seen and I
and and he was right and that combined
with it's funny the as much as the
movies were something that I really
reacted to I think even bigger and
that's why it's fun like walking walking
the floor and like seeing like seeing
that the toys and and I don't know that
that I feel like because back when back
when the movies came out it wasn't like
we had them on our iPads like it was you
had to put your name in the waiting list
at the video store and then you got the
VHS and then you and your friends
watched it for 24 hours straight it was
like you didn't actually get to see the
movie much so what you had were those
toys and I think even more than the
experience of the film the fact that the
first stories we were telling in our
heads as kids were in that universe with
those toys I think that's why I'm sure
like I think several people have said
when we walk when I walked on the good
have the same experience of walking on
the Falcon set for the first time and
unexpectedly kind of really getting
choked up out of nowhere and what it was
is flashing back to being a kid and all
the stories I told inside my Kenner in a
back of the Falcon yeah exactly and
suddenly you're standing in it and there
is just a intense emotional reaction
that that happens so anyway that's
that's that's that for the business so
now as I was saying before you now have
Luke Skywalker and Princess Leia and
c3po and r2 and Chewbacca in front of
you with your rolling camera and you're
telling him what to do I mean what's
that what's that like for you well it's
it was it was a very I mean it was an
incredible experience on many different
levels ultimately though you know in
order to and this was one of the things
that the whole process was kind of about
you come it you come into it with those
feelings of deep nostalgia but then you
realize your responsibility ultimately
is to get beyond that very quickly and
to ultimately I don't know ultimately
tell a story that it feels
live right now that's about where you're
at right now I guess and that I guess
was kind of like the ultimate
responsibility of it is to sit in front
of marks in front of Luke Skywalker and
then have those feelings of sitting here
talking to Luke Skywalker's it's kind of
weird and it's yeah and then to get to
know Mark and get to know him as an
actor and then start working through the
script and then get back into the actual
work of filmmaking and telling a story
the same way that you do with any other
film basically you know to get to the
point where you're just I don't know if
I've been expressing this right but um
but it was a it was surreal all around I
guess and now under for the new cast
you've got you know Daisy and and John
or back Oscar's back they've all kind of
Adams back they've all had their first
oh my goodness I'm in Star Wars
experience with the last film so how did
you find them coming into this movie
they were wonderful and it was it you're
right there was that kind of feeling of
there was a big explosion of the first
one and now the second Edie but it it
ended up serving I think what this
second film is in a very good way
because the first film was this is this
incredible explosion of adventure and
excitement that sets up these characters
and then just out of necessity it's very
natural that the second film is where we
start kind of zooming in on the
characters and kind of taking them
seeing okay really kind of getting to
the heart of them and challenging them
pushing them deeper and so I think the
actors were all very excited about that
yeah so you are one of I think the first
you are the first director who had a
public presence on social media before
we announced that you were our director
that would I had yeah yeah an addition
as an additional bullet point under IMDB
trivia for anyone who's editing that so
so what was that like because you were
so accessible the world to be honest the
world knew before we were even able to
formally announce that you were
directing episode 8 so you must have got
a lot of traffic coming your way
asking that to confirm or to talk about
it online yeah it's been I mean I've
been on I mean I I love being I love
being on the internet I love being like
I've always loved social media even with
like my first film that I did brick
which was before Twitter it was thank
you we said way way back before this
Twitter existed but I created like a
message board on my website for people
to come and talk about that I've always
really just loved being out the end and
I guess I was a little a little nervous
in terms of what what something on this
scale would do what I still be able to
enjoy it the way I have before and so
far it's it's been it's been wonderful
so far it's still been you know the same
sort of thing of just engagement with
people and you know so I don't know so
far so good it just feels kind of very
continuous we have any people here who
follow Ryan on Twitter or Instagram
another I apologize apologize well
speaking of Instagram you've been very
generous and sharing some photos from
the set that you yourself took during
the making of this movie so we have some
here I don't know we can show them up
and let's see if there's any stories to
tell this is that oh these are our
fantastic
background crowd who are in the who were
in that who are in the film it's funny
you you realize you realize as you do
these films how important how important
the background players are and you
realize how deeply embedded they are
from the original films and here had
some of the background you start paying
more and more attention to them as
you're directing and we we had a really
really great crowd that really took to
it and gave a great performance in the
background the scenes my name is black
and white this looks like you're making
a period picture dear there's a lot of
it and there's some shots of I don't
know if they're in here but like Gary
our cameraman when he kind of has a 70s
fro a little bit and when he's behind
that camera
like on a dolly in like a you know
resistance hall in a ship hallway you
look at the SHA then you're just like
that could be yeah that could be from
the 70s cool
let's take a look another photo here
yeah that's uh yeah so there I think
that's Billy anything that's Billy
Laurie Barry's got her there actually
and we actually I know for a lot of the
stuff I've posted I apologize that a lot
of it is kind of green screen in the
background and that that's M agree not
to put down green screen it's a great
tool but I just haven't wanted to like
give anything away but I just want to
let everyone know the amount of sets
that we've built for this movie has been
absolutely outrageous and a tremendous
amount of practical sets and we also had
the luxury of doing things like this
where we build exterior interior sets of
some of the ships so we not only would
be able to film inside them but also do
shots from the outside that weren't just
like window comps and actually move into
them so yeah we and we had fun X photo
please ah this is Ireland uh so yes got
people from Ireland great loved
Ireland's yes uh so that yeah and and in
addition to two sets with a big for a
chunk of the film we went out to Ireland
and actually in addition to Skellig we
shot along the southwest coast of the
west coast of Ireland's a lot of really
incredible locations and it was amazing
getting out there a ways into the shoot
and then suddenly having this whole
other texture to the film open up in
front of you and just the natural beauty
of that coastline and to be able to put
these actors out there and did actually
put them out and just film it and see
this stand behind the camera and and
have it feel like that it's it was it
was just incredible yeah well let's take
a look at another one here Oh who's that
guy who's that guy
I was very lucky to have the man in the
cowboy hat come out to visit several
times and spend some time on set and
yeah it's you just immediately feel calm
and at peace when Dave Filoni is
standing back behind you you feel like
everything's going to be okay I got to
say I mean we we talked about it a lot
but it's true Kathy and kiri make it's
so accessible that any part of Lucasfilm
that will benefit from being on the set
and anyone that you would benefit from
having on the set that that
communication and that you know flying
from from from one side of the world to
the other to come and help each other
out that that that's a reality of making
Star Wars movies now well it was nice
like even the time that I talked about
when we when I was in San Francisco
coming up with the story Gareth was
there and they were coming up with rogue
at the same time it would be like right
down the hall they were working on the
rogue and you'd come down and just say
hi and take a look at the whiteboard and
talk through stuff and and then dave was
doing you know just doing rebels in the
same stages right there in the Presidio
and it had this kind of campus like feel
that I know it's pretty cool cool next
photo
aha
yes should these helmets man these
helmets are bigger than you think like
you see pictures of them you see him on
screen and then you see them in real
life and you're like really my god
they're like they're massive and also
every any time any time that we were
shooting a scene with these guys and
helmets
I would I would start playing Daft Punk
is playing in my house on my phone
really loud I think it got annoying
everyone let's see do we have anymore
ah yes uh-huh
yes this is actually Oh this is my
assistant leo who we stuck in a TIE
fighter outfit and
that I had a lot of fun direct directing
him ruthlessly but but it was it was it
was I don't know this is another one of
those shots though where and there were
a few of these sets where that you know
this or some of the stuff in the Falcon
or the x-wings where you put them in
there and you frame them up and you look
at the monitor and you're just like oh
my god you just have that instant
connection to it I guess that's pretty
cool let's see if we have any more no we
don't all right no yesterday yeah so I
guess you know this is probably it's not
the best-kept secret in the world but
the production in for Star Wars Episode
eight who here knows it so bass players
barry productions done i think it was
kind of a code name code man that's
right yeah we yeah yeah yeah yeah I
gotta say it had yeah we all every one
of our projects have code names we're
not gonna tell you what it is otherwise
it defeats the purpose of telling what's
grown it is but you knew episode 7 was a
vo everything else coming forward has
additional ones but I have to say
completely biased but space bear is the
best one it just made me so happy
because that Panda logo was like every
time I saw that unofficial stuff it just
made me so happy like on like officially
printed budgets and stuff to see that
dumb little panda in his helmet up in
the corner it's like the story that I
don't know if this is true but that
terry gilliam named his production
company for one of his films poopoo
productions just so the lawyers would
have to write it well maybe we can look
forward to some space fair merchandise
at celebration next year that'd be
amazing but on that topic because you
know this is the in many ways it's the
rogue one celebration I mean Gareth had
a great spotlight moment on this stage
to tell the world about his movie next
year I think that's going to be your
time to have a big showcase moment and
it also happens to be the 40th
anniversary of Star Wars so
so what I'm saying is what we're gonna
be an Orlando aren't you I think of it I
think I'll be there okay I'm looking
forward to it and I am by the way this
is kind of like the first time I'm
coming out and kind of talking about
this thing that we've been doing and I
was very nervous about to come out here
but just like seeing all you guys and
seeing just the I don't know the warmth
and the yeah yeah I'm really looking
forward to the to the next year and a
half I'm really looking forward to
showing you guys more and more what we
got and I think we're all going to have
a really good time together
would anyone be interested any fans of
fn-2187
now when we started this panel actually
had Kerry and Cathy talk about Ryan
when Ryan wasn't here so that we
wouldn't embarrass him but now that he's
out here feel free to embarrass him what
was it like to work with Ryan Johnson as
your director no Ryan is awesome
Ryan's awesome I always like to say that
he's doing an Indian movie with in a
studio franchise the characters have
been pushed in their new direction in a
very very cool way and we're having fun
we're having really really good fun this
is true yep any spoilers the waters let
me let me let me let me think you got
one right here no no you want to find
out some spoilers I'm not gonna do that
but I do want to address something here
without spoilers for people who are
deeply concerned about Finn because when
we left him he was in a coma so can you
assure us you actually walk around and
talk and move and do something in the
episode aid or things okay that's what
I'm just trying to get we did at some
point joke that it would be great to
just have him be in the coma for the
whole night you just keep cutting back
to him it's just like this eyelids
flutter slightly these mothers something
but it but that the story is very very
interesting is that and I've done this
before so it's very very interesting to
just keep it kind of like secret no
absolutely absolutely but in terms of
the process the production I mean how
did you how did this shoot compared to
to the force awakens because the force
awakens what's your first exposure being
a Star Wars fan on a Star Wars set yeah
did any of that kind of I mean a little
bit was Maya Han Solo action figure that
I had from episode 7 yeah remember that
guys there's more signatures on it
it's just gets better as a Star Wars fan
I get to come into work I enjoy my time
with you know new members of cast and
obviously Ryan's great with a new energy
and a new take on a real story and and
it feels like Star Wars but then at the
same time we have a new director to lead
us in an interesting path so it's really
really fun I'm having fun so how much
has your life changed now that you know
you are Finn a star of Star Wars I mean
I just got back from Tesco's so and know
seriously seriously and no one bothered
me but you know it's it's been it's been
fun this is strange to see all these
figures still it's something that I
haven't taken in you know oh man you're
playing Han Solo man damn oh man
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy but
it's been great and the Star Wars fans
have been amazing it's like the best
fandom to be a poll it's really really
cool so any words of advice for all in
here I don't know man
I really don't know but you know you're
gonna be fine I mean you got that charm
stuff done doing and he's smiling just
like huh
this is great now it's gonna be fun very
very good experience man obviously
you're you're great head on you so you
enjoy the right thank you
oh man you know one one person that I
met briefly a my son I stay here because
I've been here for a while and here we
could talk about it briefly because I
really enjoyed meeting her was Kelly
Marie Tran and and this is her first big
movie and it's a big Star Wars movie and
and you know two of you have worked with
her if you could talk about working with
her and I am so excited for you guys to
meet Kelly and this is a basil in good
time and and I think yeah it did I don't
know I don't want to say too much also
because I want her to be able to come
out and present herself properly down
the line but she's really something
special man she is really something
spent a lot of great energy and a great
addition to our Star Wars family this is
a family that keeps growing look I mean
we've got the prequel trilogy
represented here with with Ryan and John
and we've got the new standalone
programs represented here with Chris
Phil and Alden and and it just feels
like we need a we need to represent the
classic trilogy here don't we we need to
really fill out this family portrait so
without further ado please welcome Mark
Hamill and Carrie Fisher
ah
you know it's moving in a way because
you can tell you're part of people's
childhoods and it's like this palpable
exuberance I mean it's sometimes I just
get lightheaded with it I have to think
of something else or I just faint dead
away seriously I know you do but really
thank you so much I can't tell you you
come through the line and I'm really
tired but it's it's it's something that
just gives me a charge like I can't
explain I'm so grateful for it
your turn uh what he said higher voice
no he ain't heavy he's my brother and it
is it is like what it's like family and
the great thing about the movie is that
those of you that have children that
have impregnated people can take those
signing humans and take them to these
movies and see which characters they
respond to and all that stuff is so
awesome and you bring a little tiny tiny
just warn people in Princess Leia
outfits which I appreciate because I
think that you swallow those outfits so
the baby doesn't come out nude which
would be so embarrassing so it's just
it's a fantastic thing it is that theory
beautiful very interesting theories you
have to think about that yes why we're
very sibling it very deep thank you food
we've been fighting back though I like
that we like with an American accent
besides on it's lovely fall yeah what is
the matter with you oh you can't take me
anywhere I brought you here are you
uncle and I promise you I'd be on my
best behavior
you know something people say are you
guys really like brothers and sisters I
said yeah we fight all the time
we were not speaking to each other for
years at a time
now we're not speaking to each other but
you have a shared experience and darn it
I will defend her with my life
because she still drives me crazy it's a
dirty job but someone's got it yes it is
why'd you drive her crazy
he'll demonstrate that throughout the
evening darling you're a damned
exasperating woman that was actually
Thornton Wilder's first title the
working title for merchants of Yonkers
was a damned exasperating I was hoping
you'd bring that up I hope it eventually
became Hello Dolly see I have I'm a font
of you has so many stories like that and
that is what Star Wars is about
absolutely this is actually the new
sequel I know about it that giving that
away spill your guts well the new sequel
is about a lot of stuff with Hello Dolly
yes that's right yeah hello Gary
yeah and I'll make sure Gary gets a part
it leads to the next one I think than
that there are dogs in this universe
cars without which there are no dogs are
there there should be Oh Chris come on
there should be we can make that happen
we have the power to you guys there are
you have pets in space right all right
that's my contribution and we and we
love you for it
Brian is this a snapshot into what your
production experience was like as well
talk to Colin talk to color it was all
it was all this and more fantastic I
can't thank you all enough for coming
and saying hi and wrapping up the
celebration and with such a memorable
way this is the Star Wars family we're
going to take some family portraits here
before we wrap and I want to remind
everyone that the closing ceremonies are
happening here work Davis has been come
out and recap one amazing past three
days this has been all of us we're going
to see you in Orlando where we're going
to be able to talk about Star Wars
Episode 8 and the untitled Han Solo Star
Wars movie please join me in thanking
these amazed
you